and now down to business that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now to all of you outside Washington you
know you've seen people out there it may
seem really odd that a large portion of
our business community supported Joe
Biden in 2020 and still support him now
our GDP corporate profits consumer
spending investor confidence they were
all strong under Donald Trump until
essentially the pandemic hit and by the
end of 2020 things were poised for a
rocket-like recovery but of course we
know what happened next
[Applause]
everything's falling and it keeps
happening check out some of the stories
from today Biden's High interest rates
and stay-at-home Slackers of course
pushed a significant spike in
delinquencies on mortgage bonds that are
tied to Office Buildings now investors
have been watching for this since last
summer and they say this may represent a
Tipping Point for our economy and then
this warning from Macy's about consumer
spending they miss their quarterly sales
estimate and we're also seeing reports
that U.S Hotel developers are running
out of cash as construction lending is
drying up
now this is grim so why does Big
Business have such a man crush on the
shuffler in Chief
doesn't this mean we need I guess at
this point a more establishment style
Republican friendly to the pro-china
Wall Street crowd to try to compete
against Joe Biden
well I got to say to that how did that
work out for republicans and we
nominated the consummate pro-business
Republican Mitt Romney in 2012.
in 2016 we saw candidates like Jeb Bush
Ted Cruz John Kasich and others Ron you
know more on a pro big business uh
platform even pro-globalization platform
and they all failed and now we have
Nikki Haley and Tim Scott and soon of
course we have now Mike Pence running on
the same platform again though where's
the enthusiasm for any of their policies
this is why the left is so scared of
both Trump and DeSantis
they represent a different world view
now back when Ronald Reagan was leading
the conservative movement into battle
against Jimmy Carter the business
Community was truly at that time
terrified about what was happening to
the U.S economy
but today our Fortune 500 CEOs they're
not sweating high taxes especially with
Republicans in charge of the house these
days taxes and regulations they're a
much bigger headache for middle-class
drivers than for the one percenters
now look if you really want to
understand the political mindset of our
wealthiest Business Leaders today you
needed to watch the private jet traffic
to Shanghai and to Beijing over the past
few weeks
call it a CEO parade in China leaders of
some of America's biggest companies are
there this week Starbucks CEO is in town
and this follows a string of recent
visits over the last few months from the
leaders of Apple Samsung oromco
Volkswagen the list goes on Jamie dimon
is in Shanghai as well according to the
Chinese defense Ministry musk reportedly
said he opposed decoupling describing
the countries as Inseparable like quote
conjoined twins Tesla did not
immediately respond to our request for a
comment
but maybe with the exception of mosque I
think all of those CEOs would prefer
Biden over Trump or DeSantis
now much of the business Community is
post-american they're focused on
maximizing profits within the so-called
rules-based International order even if
that ends up really shafting American
workers in the process they don't care
they have no problem using slave labor
in China to make their goods and they
like the prices that China pays for
their own intellectual property
and even when China buzzed our
surveillance plane made aggressive moves
across the bow of a U.S naval vessel
last week Biden officials continue it's
the most embarrassing thing I've ever
seen to publicly grovel in front of
China
yeah I think the fact that we were able
to get two officials there to Beijing
here while we're talking is a good sign
we want to keep those lines open it's
important especially as I said now
so the message is clear
if you want closer relations with China
in 2025 you better be supporting Biden
and the Democrats and of course business
also loves the open border more
immigration Sanctuary policies whatever
brings an unlimited supply of cheap
labor they're going to be for
oh and on the wokeness front let's not
stop there let's drop the notion that
the left is bullying big business into
moving to the left on all these cultural
issues
that's just a lot of nonsense yeah there
are a lot of corporate Chieftains who
are scared and you know they're scared
as they are rich and they don't have the
stomach for much of a fight with the
drag queen lobby but it's just as likely
that the CEOs themselves are simply
becoming more woke
now these companies are led by
Executives who went to the same Elite
left-wing schools as their friends in
the media
these people aren't adopting Dei and
spreading cultural leftism because it
makes them money many cases it doesn't
they're doing it because at some point
they end up believing it
this all means that the GOP needs a plan
B
a multi-ethnic coalition of middle class
and working-class voters voters who care
about economic growth here who are wary
of China and we're fed up with the
cultural Marxist turning Society upside
down
and to that point a protracted fight
over abortion and transgenderism on its
own I think is still exactly what the
Democrats are hoping for because they
know they're going to lose an economic
debate they want to stay as far away
from that as possible
they know America is getting poorer they
know we're getting weaker Democrats all
know it but they just don't care
they would much rather spend their time
discussing climate change or how love is
love
now Republicans who stay stuck in that
quicksand exclusively are going to
struggle to climb out
the candidate who keeps the focus on the
practical
can however break through
so this is really not the time for vague
discussions about Freedom like you know
this is 19 1984 or even 2004 this is a
time for pragmatic Solutions
time to drop the Nostalgia campaigns
it's time to get down to business and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else